[Musique]
c'est craquelins inspiré d'une recette
norvégiennes sont fabriqués à saint
narcisse est vendu sur internet
c'est bien car l'épaisseur à la même que
le craquelin norvégien isabelle manille
a démarré son entreprise
la fabrique gourmande en 2016 ce que
j'ai modifié par commença d'avoir un
craquelin qui étaient faits à base de
sarrasin parce que l'on utilise siècle
on sait que la farine de sarrasin est
très reconnu en mauricie ça nous
permettait de faire un fond d'oeil un
produit très localement quels sont les
ingrédients utilisés principalement à la
base c'est des grains alors c'est des
graines de tournesol des graines de
citroën et graines de sésame
il ya des flocons d'avoine de la farine
d'avoine et de la farine de sarrasin
on n'est pas habitué à un craquelin qui
est craquant comme ça on est tellement
habitué aux biscuits soda que qui est un
traditionnel craquelins on est dans un
cas quand même beaucoup plus avec plus
de texture je veux faire depuis un bon
moment de révolution dans l'univers du
craquelin cet aliment tout simple que
j'oserais dire que ces aliments
réconfort qu'on a dans nos vies depuis
qu'on est tout petit qu'on aime ce
craqué dans une soupe ou manger avec
avec un bon fromage
nous avons demandé à isabelle marquis
d'analysé 35 crack le nouveau genre
vendus en épicerie aujourd'hui avec une
roue craquer on est complètement
ailleurs c'est déborde de grains entiers
de crèmes de légumes de fines herbes
épices de toutes sortes
le type et la variété de grains entiers
et de graines qui sont utilisés dans les
cra qui aujourd'hui sont vraiment
intéressants comme le sarrasin comme le
chinois par exemple on parle de l'union
par deux chiens on parle de sésame blanc
noir c'est très très très variés marc
andré lavergne et chef à l'hôtel
mortagne l'on vous a apporté des
représentants et digne représentant de
la nouvelle catégorie en vogue c'est à
dire les dirigeables
ce sont les sens justement le mélange à
gré dont une soutenue cherchant en
bouche le craquant super intéressant ça
peut être une belle assise pour aller
justement accompagné par un petit canapé
ou quelque chose ça fait quelque chose
qui pourrait nous donner justement le
savoir lundi script de plus en plus des
deux tiers de notre échantillon sont
sans gluten il ya une corrélation
directe entre la croissance de l'offre
sans gluten et la croissance de l'offre
de craquelins fait essentiellement de
garanties ou de game
vous m'étonnez quoi là dessus je pense
qu'on près le travail et vous comptez
neutre loges on empruntera vaillamment
avait quelque chose de plus asiatique
peut-être comment entrer que ce soit un
starter avec des savoirs plus asiatique
son côté glauque et présenteront des
salles elop pourrait devenir vraiment
intéressant
si les graines bonifie les craquelins il
faut toutefois se méfier de certaines
allégations marketing sur les boîtes on
dirait que le buzz en ce moment et tout
nouveau au niveau des grilles des
graines et avec le superlatif super le
mot super et super trop utilisé et c'est
pas 3,4 grains sont vos cracklings qui
vont vous donner un meilleur temps
meilleurs une santé général de amélioré
à l'épicerie certains craquelins sont
carrément offert aux côtés des
croustilles le craquelin devient un
nouveau concurrent à la croustille donc
nous sont aromatisés avec des aliments
qu'on utilise est peut-être moins
auparavant dans les craquelins on a quel
honneur patates douces
il ya un match avec son tour aux
betteraves ce qu'on parle de nouvelle
génération vraiment j'ai l'impression
ici ou là on est beaucoup d'entités
beaucoup de saveur gm - dans le fromage
pour se réchauffer au président
seulement aussi pour avec moi je te fais
un être pas mal accompagnées de petits
légumes frais salades fraîchement de
hyogo où est la limite d'un top 10 qui
tous genres le type de légumes qui est
utilisée s'est diversifiée et raffiné
énormément mais craquait en ligue 1 ça
existe depuis longtemps c'est des
légumes déshydraté qui sont utilisés
d'ailleurs je sais quoi parce que c'est
un crack et de légumes que c'est une
portion de légumes
autre nouveauté sur le marché les
craquelins cru qu ils ont étaient
déshydratés à basse température c'est
seul principe en fait d'un aliment cru
c'est qu'ils aient pas été chauffée à
plus de 40 degrés celsius en 4° farama
lite on a là une explosion de saveurs
c'est vraiment ça c'est très très très
très boutures avait trahison vraiment
très bien assaisonné au long des quelque
chose de plus neutre comme
accompagnement avec le craquelin est
très très présent et qu'on risque
peut-être de même se tromper vu que
beaucoup de saveur on pourrait justement
faire un mauvais mauvais mélange parce
qu'il est très douteux que vous y allez
quelque chose contre eux meurtres
masseube est jeune et oussou est trempé
on va être juste pour accompagner ce
qu'on faisait soit avec un craquement
un montage potage tout ça c'est une
super bonne idée
le fait qu'il soit cru qu'ils aient pas
été chauffé à haute température ça nous
permet de conserver une plus grande
concentration de plusieurs vitamines et
minéraux qui sont sensibles à la chaleur
ou sensibles à l'eau si sa victime
cuisson utilisant blot cela dit il ya
certains nutriments qui bénéficie la
cuisson et qui sont plus faciles à
digérer comme par exemple les fibres
lorsque le produit est écrit la
nutritionniste à catégoriser les
craquelins en deux groupes ceux de plus
et ceux de moins de 5 dollars nobel âge
les flux salle et de tous nos
échantillons se retrouve dans le groupe
des produits à moins de 5 dollars
c'est le cas notamment des trois
produits de la marque lutine aux dons
qui sont moins sans gluten et les fameux
des rebonds guérin c'est dans ce groupe
là qu'on retrouve les produits qui ont
la plus grande quantité d'additifs et
c'est le cas malheureusement deux
marques très connues notamment les
biscuits bretons et les fins au blé
voici les meilleurs choix d'isabelle
pour les craquelins de moins de 5
dollars
la bonne nouvelle c'est que quand même
plusieurs bons choix dans l'ensemble de
ce qui nous est offert aujourd'hui du
côté de notre groupe à moins de 5
dollars il ya trois fabricants ou trois
marques qui ont retenu mon attention à
partir en particulier notamment blood
aymen qui est une entreprise américaine
déjà bien connue pour ses amendes un
autre choix tu risques 8
à l'époque les productrices lui était
assez grand et assez salée on retrouve
aujourd'hui une partie de leur gamme qui
est plus que raisonnable en fait je
dirais même très intéressante
j'ai bien aimé aussi nos petits produits
des cosses de mark knowles
j'hésitais elle même dans mon top 3 à
cause de la présence d'huile de palme
dans ces produits doit par contre ce
sont des produits biologiques et pour le
reste de leurs compositions c'est
vraiment impeccable
dans le groupe des plus de 5 dollars le
choix était plus difficile parce que
globalement ce sont presque tous des
produits
abel valeur nutritionnelle gourmets avec
des formes qui sont intéressantes qui
sont créatives pour le palmarès j'ai
décidé de me concentrer sur des produits
locaux donc il est cinquième entreprise
que j'ai retenus sont tous les
entreprises canadiennes ou québécoises à
savoir biosphère énergie au maillot mise
la vitalité et tout est gourmand les
consommateurs ont donc l'embarras du
choix
peu importe leur budget ou leur goût
c'est là qu'on voit que vous avez le
pouvoir d'influencer les grandes
entreprises en alimentation en leur
préférant des produits artisanaux locaux
plus santé avec des courtes listes
d'ingrédients l'industrie n'a d'autre
choix que de s'adapter s'ils veulent
continuer à vous séduire